hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take where we can
speak now to the shadow secretary of
state for education bridget phillipson
thank you very much for being on the
program um we've been talking about uh
the chancellor rishi sunatch a speech to
the cbi he said that the government does
stand ready to do more to help families
with the cost of living crisis what do
you want to see
well i don't quite know what he's
waiting for i mean it's all very good
and well to say that he's standing ready
but families are absolutely desperate
right now they urgently need help so
labour has said that we think the
government should bring forward a
windfall tax on oil and gas producers
who by their own admission have got more
money than they know what to do with
that will provide immediate help right
now you know i hear from pensioners
who've had to turn off the heating for
weeks now because they can't afford to
heat their homes parents going without
meals because they can't afford um to
look after their children and they're
making desperate desperate choices and
they rightly expect that in those
circumstances the government will act
immediately instead we've had you know
the government telling people various
ministers saying you know work more
hours buy value goods you know a litany
of kind of excuses i think it's
insulting and out of touch and we need
action now um it's clear that you know
labour is really pushing the idea of a
windfall tax and by all accounts it is a
relatively popular policy as well but i
just wonder
you know this is the biggest cost of
living crisis since records began
actually um inflation up 9
40-year high
you know to put it into context you know
the windfall tax in the north sea is
going to raise two billion pounds at
best labor's green new deal would cost
28 billion pounds every year you're
gonna need 14 of them just to pay for
the green new deal i mean don't need
something else in the locker not just a
windfall tax what's the big idea well
the windfall tax would provide that
immediate support to families and
pensioners right now i think it's only a
matter of time by the way until the
government finally you know concede the
inevitable and follow labour's plan but
what's what's the big idea you want an
emergency budget you're going to need
more than a windfall tax in that aren't
you what what what else was in your
locker and labour's green investment
pledge would make sure that we properly
insulate our homes we know that there
are 19 million homes across the country
that aren't properly insulated so we are
more exposed than many other nations
because of that problem we've got around
insulated homes but for example take
child care another area where families
are facing real pressure at the moment
our youngest children at nursery but
also right around the school day or two
labour's children's recovery plan would
pump in investment to early years for
our most disadvantaged children we'd
also deliver breakfast clubs and
after-school activities that would
provide real help to families right now
and it's something from borrowing for
the you know the the child care and the
green new deal is that from borrowing so
what the government set out in their
corporate response was they allocated
money for that response for the covert
response we would have made that
decision to prioritize support for
children and families which would have
gone towards our children's recovery
plan we all know what children have gone
through during the pandemic the
sacrifices that were made and we know
the impact it's had on their learning
but alongside that right now families
are really facing the squeeze so if they
were extra help now on child care that
would make a massive difference okay now
i just want to talk to you a little bit
about uh westminster now a conservative
mp
arrested on suspicion of rape now of
course we can't comment on the
individual cases it's very important not
to
but it does feel like there's been an
awful lot of stories from sexual
harassment claims to mps resigning for
looking at porn to the most serious
allegations of all
is there a particular problem in
westminster with this kind of behaviour
well i think it it does take you to that
conclusion given what we've seen in
recent weeks i mean i am troubled that
the whip doesn't appear to have been
withdrawn in the case that you mentioned
initially i think what we also saw more
recently that's given rise to the
by-election and wakefield was a
conservative mp i was being convicted of
very serious offences but again where
action should have been taken sooner i
think you know there is a clear
responsibility that all of us in public
life are held to higher standards but i
think clearly given what we've seen in
recent weeks
there is a problem there that needs
addressing and this isn't just about the
conduct of mps of course westminster is
a workplace for thousands of people so
they have a right to feel safe what
should happen do we need to talk about
closing bars for example what should
happen
i i don't think that's the issue i think
it comes to really
a fundamental issue around power in our
society you know parliament reflects
some of the wider problems we see in
society around sexism and misogyny that
need to be tackled and yes there are
changes i think that still could be made
around the standard system in parliament
but actually what does that mean though
like what kind of change should happen
well i think there have been you know i
was involved in some of that as part of
the standards committee we have made
improvements but i think we need people
to feel confident in coming forward
where they have concerns about conduct
because as i say
westminster isn't just about mps
actually there are thousands of people
who work there and they like everyone
else have got the right to be in a safe
workplace just to show you this tweet uh
quickly i think i can do
on
i'm gonna whiz around this way instead
here we go right michael fabricant uh
the concerto mp i i'm expecting a strong
turnout of conservative mps at prime
minister's questions today not only to
demonstrate their strong support for
boris but also to prove they are not the
one told by the chief whip to stay at
home i'll be there and then a little uh
emoji as well um
is this a fair enough tweet or do you
think that it's in bad taste what's your
take on this i think it's an appalling
taste he seems to think it's funny but
i'm afraid you know serious sexual
offences aren't a laughing matter it's
just completely unacceptable i don't
know what he's thinking okay okay so
yeah you're not happy at all with that
tweet there now just finally while i've
got you i have to ask you
keith stammer of course is being
investigated uh by the police over
allegations he denies the allegations
but he has been invested by police over
allegations that he broke covered rules
he said if he's found guilty
he would resign
if that happens would you run
well there won't be a vacancy so that's
not going to come up that's not that is
not an eventuality that's going to
happen i'm confident i know it's not no
well there isn't a contest i look
forward to seeing kia stammer as the
next labour prime minister in downing
street and i think we've got a really
strong prospect to the next election
given the progress we've made in the
local elections and making that happen
that's all i'm interested in but if the
ball were to come loose at the back of
the scrum as someone once said would you
pick it up that's not going to happen
there's no vacancy i mean key has done
nothing wrong i'm confident that will be
the outcome when he is being
investigated by the police and he has
said that he would resign if he found
guilty to be fair so you know it's not
completely
a question from nowhere no it's also
being clear he's done nothing wrong i'm
confident he hasn't uh he's a man who
believes very strongly in following the
rules that are set um i look forward to
kiera as the next favorite prime
minister okay thank you very much for
being on the programme here today
bridgette